herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen blog
von mir und da haben wir natürlich auch
mit dabei irgendwie so ein
standardspruch geworden auf jeden fall
bis heute richtig spannend werde es
heute mittwoch 15 58 es heißt ich war
gerade im shop abgearbeitet wird pakete
verpackt wird haben sie habe jetzt quasi
feierabend also später wird noch ein
medium gedreht aber ich zeige euch in
diesem blog wie ihr ein essen für
insgesamt 14 personen hinbekommt ich
mach das alleine für 14 personen und
zeige euch wie ihr das am besten planen
können weil es kam doch ganz oft die
frage geht wie ich bekomme so und sowie
besuch was euch am besten machen wie
sich das am besten machen diese fragen
vor meistens übrigens per instagram
direktnachricht bevor wir starten muss
ich das komplette chaos hier einmal
aufräumen ist schon im hintergrund hieß
so unordentlich
es ist ja alles ist ein aufruf und
vancouver starten und die gäste in dem
fall haben das gestern seine freunde
eingeladen
die sind für morgen zum iftar eingeladen
das heißt ich habe jetzt noch eineinhalb
tage das ganze vorzubereiten und dann
nehme ich euch richtig schön mit von a
bis z soeben wenn ich für mehrere also
viele personen koche dann mache ich mir
immer nutzen das ist das ist mir einfach
drin ich habe mir zu alles auf was es
bei uns alles geben wird morgen nachdem
wir euch einfach mal aufschreibt was es
alles gibt könnt ihr viel besser
einschätzen welche dieser dinge auf
meiner liste kann ich heute schon machen
denn ich finde es immer so anstrengend
am selben tag alles zu machen man kann
es so viele sachen vorbereiten haben und
ich wollten heute zum beispiel auf jeden
fall noch ein video drehen deshalb ist
es jetzt an alles ist heute auf jeden
fall schon erledigt ist kann nicht durch
streichens nach wie jetzt und dann sehen
wir uns gleich wieder
ich versuche immer alles möglich hier
für euch mit zu filmen damit natürlich
ihr auch in die rezepte hat und wie auch
content haben macht sinn oder
und ich mache jetzt hier eine große
menge ich bin schon überlegen wie ich
das im video mache entweder schreibe ich
euch die menge so wie sie jetzt hier
steht das sind zwei riesen bleche oder
ich glaub ich zusätzlich noch mal die
halbe menge auf das schau ich gleich mal
spontan
die hälfte man ja aber das ist schon
recht fehlt hier könnte es vielleicht
doch auch so wenn also bei mir so sein
wie man fertig macht köpfte dann laden
sich alle selber ein im komm her dürfte
es einfach nur das ist ja mein lieblings
fast food feierabend wir haben im kasten
und wie das doch geschehen
wir sind fertig da ist es ja auf jeden
fall mache ich jetzt weiter und wir
arbeiten ist die liste auch mal gucken
was war noch so drauf stehen habe ich
weiß nicht ob das schon online ist wenn
dieser block gerade online
leute es ist so lecker ist ja ich glaube
dann kriegen die soße ist ein kleiner
live-act das sind zwei zutaten und ihr
habt eine richtig tolle so was glaubt
ihr gar nicht was da drin ist aber ich
verrate euch nicht zu viel mist
einschalten du kannst mich mal genau
jetzt gehe ich nur meine liste entlang
und schaue was kann sich im kühlschrank
halten was kann ich heute schon
vorbereiten dass ich es morgen nicht
mehr machen muss damit ich morgen auch
einen entspannten tag habe und mich gar
nicht abhetzen muss und es gibt übrigens
auch alle rezepte die ich zubereite
entweder schon auf meinem youtube kanal
und wenn nicht dann kommen sie noch wie
zum beispiel jetzt öfter rezept das ist
schon abgedreht und ganz viele haben
auch gefragt wie soll ich denn jetzt die
mengen ausrechnen wie viel ich machen
soll nicht dass am ende viel zu viele
oder zu wenige ich rechne das immer so
pro erwachsene sind ungefähr 180 bis 200
gramm fleisch und eine handvoll von der
einen beilage in hand voll von einer
anderen beilage und dann sind die mengen
optimal und ich persönlich bin immer ein
fan von lieber sohn theken zu viel als
zu wenig denn bei uns wird nichts
weggeschmissen
alles was liegen bleibt wird entweder am
nächsten tag gegessen selbst wenn das zu
viel ist sagen wir so viel familie dass
das definitiv verteilt wird
die linsensuppe berate ich jetzt am
abend zu die tu ich nach dem erkalten
den kühlschrank dann ist sie morgen
nämlich auch noch wunderbar frisch dass
honig senf dressing hält sich im
kühlschrank drei tage
das bereite ich auch jetzt schon zu die
hähnchenkeulen die mache ich erst morgen
die soße dafür kann ich heute schon
machen habe ich also auch erledigt
leicht zurück kräfte wird morgen gemacht
den reisen mache ich definitiv morgens
frisch aber die kirche kerne die kann
ich ja heute schon an button das heißt
selbst diesen schritt erledige ich heute
und auch die zigarette
die werde ich heute schon ein rollen so
dass ich zum morgen einfach nur noch in
den ofen schieben kann fett der widmung
frisch gemacht das zeige ich euch den
morgen und der kuchen meine banana split
orte da überlege ich noch ob ich im bett
kochen macht den erledige ich auch schon
heute und schon ist die liste immer
immer kleiner so meine suppe ist fertig
die wo siehst du noch pariert werden
aber ich es mir damit zeit denn ich
mache jetzt noch was anderes und zwar
mache ich meine banana split tisch
verlinkt euch das mal hier oder hier
ich weiß es gab nicht verlegen mich auf
jeden fall die torte und ich habe das
doppelte rezept genommen das ist so wie
leute in berlin den 26 er springt vom
habt also das rezept für eine 26
ausgelegt ist da verdoppelt ihr einfach
das rezepten dann könnt ihr ganzes blech
vollhauen damit oder andersrum wenn ihr
wenig besucher erwartet oder ich weiß
nicht ihr seid nun zu zweit oder zu
dritt oder zu viert dann gibt es noch
was anderes moment dann habe ich die
spitzenform die schnieken form ist
nämlich immer genau dann perfekt
geeignet wenn ihr ein 26er rezept
halbieren möchte
das heißt wenn die nicht so viele seid
wenn ihr sagt doch alles liegen das
schafft doch kein mensch auch zu essen
dann schnappt ihr euch meine schlitten
form halbiert das rezept und das ist
genau hier rein aber bei 14 9 wird hier
nichts halbiert sondern nur verdoppelt
und ich habe meinen schoko boden
vorbereitet und den bug ich jetzt mache
ich okay und hamza vergisst die bonbons
nicht mehr nur pakete gepackt
[Musik]
während der kurven boden jetzt abkühlt
kümmere ich mich um die basics ich mache
meine berühmt-berüchtigten panierten
zigarette rix das ist jetzt für die
kartoffel füllung ich mache jetzt aber
auch noch eine chance diese füllung so
während ich hier die kartoffeln schon
mal so ein bisschen kleiner drücke ganze
mitteilen dass ich euch das rezept
natürlich in die infobox packe soll es
ist alles vorbereitet ihr lieben und ich
will jetzt alles das seht ihr aber im
zeitraffer
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich das meiste geschafft also
wenn die liste ist eigentlich
abgearbeitet wie heute und morgen mache
ich weiter und was ja auch am vortag
schon machen können ist das hähnchen zu
marinieren
also die komplette soße ich weiß nicht
ob das rezept schon online ist das hat
mit dem von catan erst gefilmt aber es
müsste eigentlich schon online sein und
dann fühle ich euch die linke natürlich
auch rein und das könnte auch super am
vorabend schon machen
[Musik]
so die linsensuppe ist püriert hier habe
ich solo crafter das rezept gibt es ja
schon deswegen wollte ich euch das jetzt
unnötig doppelt zeigen
die habe ich schon meine platten mit ski
kräfte fällig und jetzt gibt es reis und
den mache ich jetzt schon der bleibt er
im topf richtig schön war mit zusammen
war ungefähr noch anderthalb stunden bis
zum iftar gewünscht und der alltag ist
[Musik]
ja zum glück ist ja voll abgelenkt ich
bin wieder da ich lebe noch
für euch ist es jetzt her die heutige
wetter aber ich war in den letzten
stunden im stress weil ich alles
vorbereitet heute und irgendwie sind sie
die letzten zwei stunden vorstand vor
stress sich in dem sich vorstellen die
küche sieht vor dem start immer
ausgesagt und danach auch und jetzt hat
der hansa nur handy aufnahmen gemacht
ich hoffe ich kann ich habe euch jetzt
was brauchbares eingeführt gerade er
wirkt sehr gesehen haben
jetzt zeige ich euch mal wie die küche
aussieht hier ist eine bombe
eingeschlagen seien
unsere couch kommt bald nicht wundern
und ich muss die aufräum- und natürlich
hilft der haben samir al hamsa ein
beispiel dran nehmen nur wasser trinken
und ich habe noch keine suppenschüsseln
deswegen haben wir uns die jetzt von
haben sie es nochmal genommen weil er
war heute mittag noch da und da hat er
gleich mal zehn suppenschüsseln oder
zwölf oder vierzehn ich weiß es nicht
auf die suppenschüssel mitgenommen und
wir haben jetzt gerade mal 41 in der
nacht ich war kein live auf instagram
habe mich so ein bisschen ablenken das
nicht liebe das mich ablenken zu lassen
vor irgendwelchen arbeiten habe ich gut
gemacht eine stunde
und jetzt muss ich wirklich sagen jetzt
gibt es keine ausreden und ich habe mit
james virgin angefangen könnte die serie
ich brauche manchmal serien wo ich
einfach mein gehirn ausschalten und das
ist einfach so gesehen ein hirn
ausschalten glotzen und ich glaube dass
ich jetzt laufen nebenbei während ich
auf es ist so kriegst du von der
gießkanne geht die army richtig dresche
richtig berger für diesen satz möchte
ich natürlich nicht deswegen fand
raphael 321
[Musik]
so damit kann ich auf jeden fall leben
und was noch übrig ist mache ich morgen
ja haben wir haben echt eine gute hilfe
für heute nehme ich euch gerne nochmal
mit durch den abend wir haben gerade ein
süßes rezept gedreht und zwar also viele
haben sich von mir gewünscht ist gibt es
war schon ein original jordanische
skinner für also knapp vor meine
schwiegermama aber zum beispiel ich
kenne das ja auch selber aus der türkei
wird das ganz anders zubereitet und das
habe ich heute gemacht aber weil die
form einfach rund bei mir müssen zu
langweilig und deswegen habe ich gedacht
machen wir mal richtig schön passend zum
ramadan folgende und zwar ist das eine
mondsichel schaut mal hier fehlt schon
ein stück weil wir das ja grad an
schnell und fotografieren mussten aber
wenn ihr das zu hause zubereitet habe
ich jetzt ein live hacks für euch ihr
cloud euch ein stück nach
und dann macht ihr so und das wie sieht
wieder aus wie am anfang und so könnt
ihr euch ein stück land kein mensch
gemerkt ich hab so richtig lust auf die
kräfte das video müsst ihr morgen online
kommen bisher war ganz schön knapp dran
haben sie sonst also deine verteidigung
da stimmt wohl jetzt seine kippe auch im
short ich glaube nicht dass jemand von
den zuschauern mit großem gewinn
verkauft sie sei es ist kurz nach acht
ich muss jetzt die küche so ein bisschen
auf vordermann bringen
die ganzen lichter abbauen zur seite und
haben sie macht nur schnell wieder zu
ende
und dann geht es heute auswärts essen
haben sie hat gesagt ich habe heute noch
verbot fand ich richtig nett weil es
wenn ich nicht viel
und ganz ehrlich foot locker hin oder
her ab und zu mal sich bedienen lassen
und verwöhnen lassen es auch mal schön
dass freue ich mich jetzt ich weiß noch
nicht was wir essen also welche richtung
aber ich hoffe ja insgeheim
auch afghanische wird noch mal was ist
euch aufgefallen ist meine haare gefärbt
hat zwischendurch aufgefallen jetzt
sieht man so richtig gerade im job hat
uns gar nicht gesehen
ich wollte ja eigentlich als wurde
dunkel bleiben sondern ganz wichtig dass
ich mich einmal so ein gezwungenes
helfen weil es gar nicht zu mir
strähnchen ein bisschen braun
dunkelbraune haare schon immer in der
natur aus ein bisschen hellbraun sollte
drin haben dann ist endlich mal gewagt
aber die frage aller fragen nicht sehen
würde aber nicht aus der ist ja an sich
ja richtig schade richtig schade einfach
nur hergekommen zum start
es ist jetzt so halbe stunde vor aber
ich möchte darüber berichtet ja auf
jeden fall hatte haben wir reserviert
und eine anrufliste steht um 14 uhr
angerufen zwei personen und die haben es
einfach nicht gemacht wenn es einfach
nicht gemacht dass ein traummann
der lohn
die anderen abschnitte trockenreifen
selbst
[Musik]
nochmal ein
ja kaum co hat nicht umsonst ein großes
herz an der scheibe die haben nämlich
auch ein großes herz für pittis und
hamza reservierung nicht
entgegengenommen
ja auf jeden fall haben wir uns überlegt
uns die beine zu vertreten haben
wo könnte man hin und jetzt gibt es ja
in duisburg sein kleines fest
ja und da gehen wir jetzt hin teppich
kommen
siegen
das ist zufall
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
war
gekauft
und jetzt gibt es nach hause mit unseren
[Musik]
ich mache gar nichts mehr ohne das also
nicht mehr unbeobachtet ist nie das
kommt immer mit auf schritt und tritt
nach der freundlich gar nicht
jetzt haben wir gegessen und jetzt kommt
der nachtisch auszulachen läuft sagen da
front da hinten wenn man sagt es ist
auch das kommt vom syrer in bochum
[Musik]
dieses gesagt hast du schon mal gemacht
na ja das verlegen ich euch auch in die
info box zum hoch vision ag wenn ich
irgendwann ich bei instagram und die
hälfte zu rasieren muss man dann einfach
auf sein stück drauf machen dann kann
man so sehen
das ist ein tag aus mozzarella und innen
ist entweder mascarpone oder
milchprotein auf jeden fall sehr lecker
nach dem start alle so nur am handy ja
das war's vom blog wir hoffen euch
gefallen
und natürlich viel wasser trinkt
kommentieren und beim nächsten mal auch
wieder einschalten
warum und ansatz zwillingsschwester da
gibt es einfach schön dass meine
schwester dieses bisschen klein
gewachsene schwester ich mich schon was
machen sie
[Musik]